But I pretend to send a screenshot of Abba's message saying that
he didn't want to be part of this anymore. I pretend to send
it to Myron, Myron [music] Gaines. And I never do it and I
>> Oh, no.
Oh, no. The issue is you're a crazy shiksa. That's what the problem
is. I like just imagine how much of a loser you are right now
cuz you're over here posting all this [__] online
and like all the red pillers are going to look at you like you're
a Jezebel. And if that's what you want to do, then go crazy,
>> I'll give A I WILL DOX YOUR STUPID I'LL GIVE A DEFINITELY
NOT MANIC. Definitely doing
>> Part one, my pregnancy with Abba, Libby Calloway. So
this This girl accused Abba of some stuff, okay?
Abba's getting accused of some stuff, unironically. Abba from
Abba and Preach getting accused of, I think, basically pressuring
this girl into an an into an abortion, which is very funny given
the fresh thing, all right? Just very funny. And I was a girlfriend
of Abba from Abba and Preach. We were together for 5 months and
involved with each other for about 8 months total, but 5 months
of that was a serious, committed relationship.
>> I know when someone thinks 5 months, they think, "What
can really happen in 5 months?" But I think most would agree
the first 5 months of a relationship can feel very intense and
be filled with a lot of love. And that means you can feel the
opposite of that intensity if things are not aligning or things
are not compatible.
Yeah, sure. >> to be talking about a pregnancy in which
Abba ultimately walked away from. And [clears throat] I'm going
to be talking about the difficulties and the emotional emotionally
harmful interactions I've had with Abba.
I want to acknowledge something up front, and that is I know
exactly who I'm speaking about. I know exactly who Abba is.
Abba is articulate. He is persuasive and he is helpful. Dude,
she just doesn't know the baggage of that word when you say it
about like black people in a media sense. It's just like it's
very First thing she says, "Abba's articulate." It's like, "Bro,
what are you doing?"
>> Okay, hold on. I need I need to take notes. Holy Christ,
we're going fast.
All right, awesome.
>> Wait, so he brought it up? Is that what she's saying?
He brought it up?
>> going through it that day. And when he leaves, I make
another appointment. And >> Okay, like at to this point
he sounds like it honestly sounds like okay, they've got differences.
To this point, this isn't like a cancellation or
it sounds like he's fine. Like it sounds like he's actually not
doing anything wrong at all. I canceled that one. And I think
in total I canceled
three abortion appointments. And I think, you know, maybe I should
give it more time and
see if my feelings change. And so I set an appointment for after
uh the trip I had planned to Montreal um to visit Abba.
I visit Abba in Montreal and we get into our biggest fight. And
this was a real turning point for me. [clears throat] And I know
it's hard to imagine Abba upset, but he does get there. And not
only does he get there, he goes past the point of the threshold
of being harsh and stuff. Abba resorts to name-calling and degrading
language and resorts to ridicule and mocking and
it it does teeter Uh-oh.
Uh-oh. Did he call her Ling Ling? Oh, no. Oh, no. And verbal
abusive side. And I hate to put a label on it like that, but
but it's truly what it felt like. And don't take my word for
it. Um >> I will be posting examples in this video or the
next video.
After that trip, um I realized that I always wanted to keep the
child and it was the relationship that I that needed to be looked
at. But it was never in my values to terminate the pregnancy.
I think I'm anxious about And I think it's better if we co-parent.
And I was thinking about
the kind of environment I would like to raise my child in and
and everything like that. So Abba was really upset. And we hang
up and he tells me to get the
And he tells me I don't have anything to say, just get the abortion.
And I'll wait for the abortion updates. And I said I will consider
keeping you Oh, sorry. I said, I will keep you updated. I will
consider what you said over the phone about having the abortion
and my values were to ultimately
I'm going to Listen, I I This is so hard to judge the guy on
Well, actually, I want to keep the baby, but I don't want to
I want to keep the baby, but I don't want to be in a
That's rough. That's That's like I I feel like that would be
very tough to hear. And I wait for the abortion updates. And
I said, I will consider keeping you Oh, sorry. I said, I will
keep you updated. I will consider what you said over the phone
about having the abortion and my values were to ultimately not
get it. And he said, just so we're clear, if you change your
mind for the 10th time, I will not have I will not be involved.
Um and then I kind of snap back a little bit and I'm like, then
don't be. And then he blocks me. And he blocks me for an entire
day. And
I'm so sorry for the construction in the background. I have to
make sure
>> just be quiet. Sorry about that. Um I said, hey, I need
to talk to you about the baby. I'm still blocked. And I tell
my cousin to unblock the to message him to unblock me. And he
says, hey, I blocked you for a second to say, stop contacting
me regardless of what you choose. I will never decide to keep
in contact with you. You're no longer my responsibility. Now
don't ever chat to me again. And then I'll If you guys are reading
this, I'll talk to I'll mention what's going on here in a minute,
but I said, why I said, why did you block me after you wanted
updates? He says, because I don't want updates. Sorry, it wasn't
clear. So I'll be clear. I don't want to ever hear from you again.
What did you just do here? Okay.
Now don't reach out to me again. You're threatening me because
I don't want to talk to you. Having your cousin send me black
weird blackmail threats. You get to end the relationship and
I'm within my rights to block you and not want contact. So then
something's cut off here and then it goes to this. updates. Sorry,
it wasn't clear. So I'll be clear. I don't want to ever hear
from you again. He says, keep it or don't. I don't need updates.
If you do If you do this, so be it. If you don't, then you don't.
This is rough how she's jumping around and she's not just doing
the full scroll, right? That's immediately like not looking good.
And
I Not that it'll like affect me. I'm just saying that like I
expect that there's stuff in the middle that is going to make
her look bad that she didn't want to put out and he's going to
go live and put it out. And so this is a blemish Okay. on my
part um in [clears throat] all of this but I pretend to send
a screenshot of Aba's message saying that he doesn't want to
be part of this anymore. I pretend to send it to Myron Myron
Gaines and I never do it and [laughter] I never
Oh no. Oh no. did do [laughter] it but I was just like I was
fighting back >> Okay. That's a level of mind game where
I'm like okay, I don't know Oh boy, what is Aba going live with
cuz Aba seems to think he's got something cooked up here, okay?
Holy
holy
I also messaged the Aba and Preach page and I tell him this.
I'm not going to read it but I'll leave it up here so you guys
can view and pause if you like and
I'm pregnant and despite
uh it being in a relationship or despite being in a relationship
or not you said you don't care if I keep the baby or not and
that you won't be a part of it. You told me you'd never walk
out on a child if I got pregnant and you lied. I will keep the
baby and raise them myself but because I expressed I I felt anxious
5 months into the relationship and I told you the truth because
I do care about your life me loving you and me also feeling unsettled
can both exist. You say this isn't horrible behavior towards
me. You You're saying this behavior is better than blackmail
but I I didn't even get I didn't even said I was going to do.
Um [clears throat and snorts] I finally get He He calls again
and we finally get on a phone call. This is the most brutal phone
call and
does reflect everything that I had mentioned before that Oh boy.
was brutal >> Oh boy.
contained a lot of dehumanizing language and degrading language
and Now you can see it. She's She's messing over it. She's got
it. >> have the phone call right here. Yeah, she recorded
it. Of course she did. And in this phone call he also says
I will never meet the baby. I will never look at the baby in
the face. I will never know its name. And if I do, I will make
sure to tell them that their mother was disgusting and horrible
and he says that he will make sure he's never a part of the baby's
life. And I you can't picture Abba saying this. uh
>> No, I could totally picture somebody saying it. I I
actually can. I know exactly where that comes from and like it's
going to be one of those things where it's like it's really bad
that he'd say those
But I'm sorry. Like depending on the stuff that was happening,
I think he's trying to say like I'm out no matter
I do think you you'd speak like that in a way. Depending on how
stuff was going down, man. I'm not going to have It's going to
be bad. It's I'm not going to like a vow any of the commentary.
Unlikely, at least. But I'm going to understand where it's coming
from depending on what happened before this. >> But he
does say it. And
Yeah, it's like dude, it's like the end of a relationship and
there's like baby mama drama going on at the end. It's like I
I do get it. I now have to make decision. And I have to make
a decision based off what the reality is. The reality is is that
Abba completely left me for dead. And
walked out on the pregnancy and
he is now absent from this entire thing. >> And he does
not have anything to do with me I've ever had to make and
it was a very painful decision, but I end up having the abortion.
And I grieved very hard. And I was also grieving the relationship
with Abba. I knew that I found all of these incompatibilities,
but I did still love him a lot. And I was Did you say left for
dead? Yeah, I
I think Abba will never get a hold of me again and he Welcome
to Canada, [__]
Um he's here to [clears throat] to reach out, but he does. So
a week after the abortion, I hear from him on Instagram. And
this is what he says. He says, "For me to plan things, I need
clarity on a few things. Whether you intend to continue the pregnancy
and what level of involvement you foresee for me. I should be
clear that I still have no plans to
I'm not messaging to discuss the relationship or here to argue,
just the above." And he is messaging me a lot and it's because
I'm not responding to him.
one thing I realized about Abbas is
I'll be sending your job evidence of your ongoing blackmail campaign.
I'll contact the cops in your area and start the police process.
Don't forget, this is something you started when all I wanted
was to ooh the up for Dude, Abbas up here cuz the second the
second she makes that Myron threat, I feel like you stop messaging.
Cuz you know that every single one of these things that Myron
gets, he's going to make so much content out of. Unfortunately,
you just have to like basically in-person conversations are like
the only thing you would have with a third party there who can
like verify what's going on. Like those are the only conversations
you can have now once the Myron threat comes out. But I obviously
he's very in love with this woman, so he's clearly he's not thinking
clearly at all. He's like super pissed. So now we're caught up.
We're here for Abbas' response to that first video.
So if we look to fill in the gaps of like what's going on here,
he's he's referencing blackmail behavior. She says, "One time
I faked a screenshot that I was going to share things with Myron
Gaines." Of course,
she's aware of who Myron is. The fact that she even name drops
him in this video is already like pressing on
right? That Abbas doesn't want to have any of this Like obviously
Abbas knows that he's gone extremely hard on Fresh and and Myron.
Yeah, it's uh it's tough, man. Do you guys remember the memes
that Abbas was doing about how like Abbas Oh, YEAH.
I DIDN'T KNOW THIS IS A THUMBNAIL.
LET'S GO! DUDE.
You got to know you when you come at people like this, when your
[__] goes bad, you you can't even really be that
mad that they're going to pick it up and go like crazy with it,
right? What Abbas
Fresh's baby mama was he would pay child support for the kid,
I think. I think he said he would pay for child support. He would
take care He would be like the surrogate father of that kid.
It got pretty nasty when you think about it, okay?
What about the name Abba? Well, I got so many DMs already that
they want a stepping and they want to be the stepfather. Already?
[__] is stepping in trying to be the step daddy.
Stepping [snorts] in the name of love. >> I will say this.
Stepping in the name of love. If you end up having legal troubles
and they suing you and if you name that kid after me, I'll pay
for all your legal troubles.
That's a promise. So, if you need a help buying a If you name
the kid after me, I got you, Daisy. I got you. Dude.
Like as funny as it's super funny,
but realistically, that's like giga ill, right? That's like totally
crazy. That's like And now now you've got your own stuff coming
out and it's it's rough,
You need a lawyer to fight off a legit
What do you mean? If uh if Walter Jr. over there got the name
Abba, I'll pay all them bills. I'll sleep I'll Hey, listen. As
far as I'm concerned, I think you deserve every dime. What's
her name? We don't know her last name. Daisy. That's all we going
to call her, okay? Imagine Her name is Abba Preach Daisy. I'll
pay them legal fees. I will I will double the video output on
this channel to pay for little Abba Preach Daisy to get all that
child support. Every dime. If that going to have Walter genetics,
she deserves child support. Yeah, he going to need every financial
advantage to be able to make it in life and he going to have
pug CEO's genetics. I'm with it. Okay? That's a promise, Daisy.
Just drop our names. Even if it's just middle names, I'll take
that.
I just want my legacy
to live on in Yeah. Don't lie. That's gangster. I have said so.
I'll pay every >> have I said so. Oh, to be clear, guys,
I'm not joking. I will pay for the lawyer if that baby has my
name in it. You don't even know how much the lawyer fees can
be. >> I'll pay for the lawyer. For the lawyer, I guess.
Just for the lawyer. >> You don't think I got money to
spend? This will be one of the greatest hobbies I will ever undertake.
I was looking straight at the camera and I didn't >> You
better not. And I'll say this, too. I'm going to also encourage
her to make sure she share custody. So [snorts] that every time
little Abba preach Daisy go up to Walter and she go, "Papa."
Say my name.
That that
This crazy.
All right, listen. You know what they say, right? Revenge is
a dish best served with some child support. You going [clears throat]
to have
This crazy. Wait. Thank you so much. Okay. Have a good night.
All right, I'll stop. I'll stop. I'll stop. I'll stop. Never
consistent. Blah, blah, blah. What the Here we go. Here we go.
Here we go.
This is This is a crazy way to start. I It's already a bad look
for me. I just feel like you could easily come out and be like,
"Yo, I uh" Yeah, this didn't work out. Dude, I hope he's got
proof of the abortion. I really hope he's got proof of the abortion.
Could you imagine the double the double cross if she didn't abort
the kid? If she had the kid and
and then after having the kid
said, "Oh, well, I got the abortion." Could you imagine this
dance and how bad it would go or how funny IT WOULD BE?
I'M GOING TO EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT Some of y'all are like, "What
the [__] is going on, Abba?" And uh Preach is not
here right now. I actually asked if he could. He said he won't
be available till 9:30. I got to go salsa dancing around 9:30.
So he might get here just for the end. That's the reason why
he's not there. Now, some of you might read into it, "Oh, Preach
is running away." We're seeing him tomorrow, so we'll see you
guys then. But, figured I'd just get here right now to talk about
it cuz it's
Now, some of you have been following us all year know And there's
no reason to respond to this tonight when you want to go out
salsa dancing in a rushed fashion when you could just respond
tomorrow, right? You could just respond tomorrow. That around
the end of last year, going into this year, I was pretty stressed
out. I was dealing with a lot of [__] I was You know,
your boy was showing up with some social juice. Not because I
wanted to be an alcoholic. I was drinking a lot, but it was still
It was still pretty stressful period. And
the reason why it was stressful wasn't because I pulled a fresh
or a Walter. The reason why it was stressful is because I was
involved in a relationship where the other individual
How do I put this?
You know guys, today you guys are going to see me be a bit vulnerable
and be real about aspects of my life that I never want to share
with the public. Mostly because
I don't know. It involves people I know in real life, and that's
always a weird thing. But unfortunately, you know, she forced
my hand. And so I figured I'd come up here guys and be
>> Yo, Lamarr. This is karma for backstabbing Destiny.
The universe always self-corrects.
God, what a cool community that guy has. >> hate her. You
know, there's somebody I love very, very much and I loved. And
um you know, we went through something that was very, very difficult.
And it's hard for me to hate this person because for me, if I
love somebody, it doesn't just go away. And so you can be making
this for me right now. It feels weird. You [snorts] know, "Oh,
but you were just dancing 5 minutes ago." Yes, because the relationship
itself took so much out of me. You know, I can sit here in front
of you guys today Okay, that kind of makes up for what I was
saying. That's a little better. >> because I gave everything
to a relationship. Every ounce of me. More patience than I even
knew I had. And wore myself out doing everything in my body to
make things work. And it just didn't work out. And
you know, breakups are always tough because you leave thinking
like what if and this and that. But when you give everything,
when you know, like you you tried and you tried and you tried
and it just didn't work out, it's a lot easier for me to walk
away and to look back on it and speak about it because, you know,
there's nothing really much else for me to do. So now, she comes
out with this video. Didn't know what was happening, so it was
a little blindsided. I woke up at 4:00 p.m. in the afternoon.
And you guys are getting this all raw, live,
What? You woke up at about 4:00 p.m. in the afternoon? Okay.
>> that she got it raw, and that's why we're here. Okay.
So, why don't I just plug in the video a little bit so y'all
can see who we talking about. All right, this is my ex, Libertine
Garcia. All right, she's a Filipina. My first
my last. Uh I I like you Filipinos, you guys are awesome, you
know what I mean? Her family seemed really cool, so I'm always
going to say positive things about the people them. But, let's
take a look. My name is Libby. And >> what a dramatic ass
intro. But, that's who she is, okay?
>> My name is Libby. What a dramatic
Now, I'm not going to spend an hour going over this whole video
cuz I don't think it's really worth watching. The main concern
is is Aba
you know what I mean? He's got some baby mama drama, is that
what people want to
The allegation essentially is that Aba's like Aba's like fresh,
he got her pregnant and he and he just manipulated or bullied
her or whatever. I That's what I was told. I don't feel like
it was manipulating and bullying. It was like a different thing
than Fresh. Fresh was like trying to manipulate this woman into
getting an abortion. Aba was not and I don't think she presented
it that way. It seemed like Aba wanted the kid and she was unsure
about the relationship. She started thinking about it and then
eventually the relationship does go bad and then he's an and
he doesn't want to talk to her anymore. I mean, he's an in response
to something. It's basically What is he Is him being an in response
to something where it's like, "Okay, I understand how he's that
much of an apple." That'll be the question. Or he abandoned
and that couldn't be further from the
Couldn't be further from the truth. So, we'll get into all of
those details, okay? Someone said, "Oh, Aba, you're sweating
right now." To be honest with you, I really don't.
I don't live my private life in a way that I would be afraid
if it came to light. I know someone might think that, but I'm
not I'm not looking back on all my decisions in this dynamic
and going, "Oh my god, if someone I don't give a You know, I
just don't want y'all cuz it's annoying, you know what I mean?
Having people in my personal life you talking about it's like
it's annoying.
beyond that, like I'm not stressing, to be honest with you. So,
for all the people being like, "Oh my god, like" not really [snorts]
bothered. So, me and her dated for some time and
we talked at length about what we would do if she got pregnant.
And both of us landed on we would keep the child. And the reason
why we would want to keep a child is because for her she presented
herself as a Christian, someone of faith. For me um I'm pro-choice.
You guys know that. But at the same time I told myself like you
know if it's my child and it feels right and we're in a union
then I'm more than willing even if it's unexpected to assume
my responsibilities and do what I got to do. Um Okay. The three
things that she presented to me that surprised me in all this
was that once she said she would never quit, she's not a quitter,
you know what I mean? So that to me was reassuring cuz I want
to work through problems, I want to work through issues, fights,
everything. And um you know I value that in a partner. Second
thing she told me was that uh yeah you know she wouldn't get
an abortion. For her keeping children really important. So I'm
like cool, you know I can it's not my faith or anything like
that but I get that and I respect that. And the third thing is
that she's not a cheater and uh she doesn't believe in courting
the attention of other
only one reason that's Chekhov's gun right there, right? Only
one reason to bring that up. >> And this third one turns
out is the reason why we're here today, okay? Um she presented
herself as somebody who you know if I'm seeing somebody or whatever,
I wouldn't even let a man come up to me and talk to me. She you
know I I I think it's disrespectful. She presented herself like
as a woman with such strong Oh, wait. This could go either way.
Oh, this could go either >> you know entertaining other
men it almost was a lot, you know for me like if I'm seeing somebody
if they're exclusive with me that's all I really I don't need
you to know you said goodbye to someone cuz they said hi to you
at the gym or you ran away like but she felt the need to explain
to me it's a big deal to her. So I said fantastic.
now let's get to the first thing.
>> Okay. We
had these conversations about keeping children or not and I should
give you guys a little bit of background. Now you're going to
get medical information, okay? Um up until about two and a half
years ago. So so two and a half years ago I went to the doctor
and essentially I won't get to the long gist of the conversation
cuz it's none of your business. But the doctor kind of told me
like hey listen your sperm count's mad low, I don't think you
have kids. So in my head I'm like I didn't get a vasectomy that's
like kind of good news but I want to kids maybe I didn't know
but part of me was like maybe I won't. You guys I don't know
why man. Everyone is messaging me like I'm are you stressed?"
I'm like, "I'm really not." Okay. So, she gets pregnant and we
had a conversation about it and initially she's like, "Okay,
we'll do this." This is the only time that she ever told me she
wanted to have a kid.
>> And when she told me that, I said, "Okay, you know,
like I wasn't expecting this, but if this is where it's turning
then I'm going to assume my responsibilities.
>> But yeah, let's do this."
So, this happens might have been
October, I don't know. But at this point my life changes a little
bit at that point because I'm in my head. He's checking his phone.
I feel like
I feel like he's getting notifications. I feel like notifications
are coming in. PREACH BE LIKE, "WAIT!
STOP!
LET ME GET THAT!" BUT YEAH, let's do this.
I need to pull the plug. >> This happens might have been
October, I don't know. But at this point my life changes a little
bit at that point because I'm in my head now focused on dealing
with what's in front of me. I have a huge responsibility so I'm
shifting all the things in my life to shift my responsibility.
You know, I'm shifting my investments, I'm shifting my work stuff
and I have a hard time explaining this. Sorry. I hear the ding
and I'M JUST LIKE, "NO!
>> ABE, NO! YOU CAN'T DO IT, ABE!" >> YOU GUYS, I'm
listen, I've never fathered a child before. But being a dad was
something that I told myself if I was going to do I would do
it the right way. And so for me it was really important that
my life was in order. And even though I'm successful on YouTube
or whatever it could be and I'm doing fine financially, I'm doing
great. I think there's a lot of things in my personal life that
I could have in better order. You know what I mean? I could be
in some better shape. I need to take my health a little bit better
so I'm here for a long time.
Mindset, things like I was really getting ready for the prospect
of this.
A week goes by and all of a sudden I start getting messages from
her on a regular basis of her feeling unsure.
And the whole time I'm being incredibly supportive. Don't worry
guys, I'm going to show evidence of this. But for me it's very
tough because from that point on and for the next two and a half
>> she flip-flopped between I'm not sure and I'm not going
to have the child.
I could only be supportive cuz as you know, you know, this is
a man's world, but when it comes to kids, babies got control,
women got control. So,
even if I didn't want to have the kid, if she tell me no, then
that's just what it is. I told her how I felt. I told her why
I wanted to go forward with it. She felt differently, and she
wouldn't waver. And all I could do is be respectful and be supportive,
because at the end of the day, like think about my options from
my perspective. She's carrying my kid.
If I stress her out, it may result in a miscarriage. If I make
her feel alienated, it might push her toward abortion. All I
can do right now for the health of the child and for her health
as well, is to be supportive. That's all I can really do. So,
that's what I did. And uh I tried. You know what I mean? I tried.
And one time she said dead set on having an abortion, even though
I was against it, and I flew down to be with her. Not to convince
her not to have the abortion, but to be there for her through
it. Because it doesn't make sense to me to have a partner, and
they're going to go through something as traumatic as an abortion,
and I'm not there. Oh. So, right now you guys are going to hear
this is a conversation that me and her had months later after
most of this happened, okay?
Yeah, and then you going on. And [clears throat] I had Yeah,
and I knew to know that like I've been I was You're saying like
you knew what I was going like I explained the debilitating
uh decision-making like I was doing every day. I was going back
and forth every day. I was just trying to figure out what to
do, and
and [snorts and clears throat] I regret the way I handled it,
and I feel like the first two or the first few weeks I was like
thinking about you first. I feel like I was in a triangle of
like, okay, if I don't have the baby, then things can continue
going on with Abba. And but if I have the baby, then it's just
like all this pressure with
You know, I I know what you thought in your head, but like I
think the frustrating part for me is I literally flew down to
be there for you for the abortion. I don't know how things were
going to go afterwards. Like I would have supported you regardless.
But when it when it >> seem like that. It didn't You You
kept saying like you're never going to be the same. You're But
but that's just true, right? Like you are not going to be the
same either. And that's okay. Like I wasn't going to lie to you
and tell you I was going to come out the other side one way.
But I told you I'd be supportive and be there for you regardless.
I didn't go down there to convince you not to do it. I went down
there believing you were really going to do it.
That's why I went down there. I you dude, I uh I can't help but
think this is just a massive mistake and this is like an emotional
response. Yeah, I'm guessing both recorded the calls. He shouldn't
be I don't think you should be playing this. This is way too
>> like you want to talk about it and you want to talk
about it when I came down. You you were trying to comfort me
and I said it's okay. I know but you were having a hard time
and you Sorry, I'm not going to argue with you. You don't think
that I look at you and I don't care about how you feel. Like
you don't think at the time I'm like seeing you and I do [clears throat]
love you and I'm like looking at you and I'm like this baby is
devastated. >> And then part of me is like I also don't
want to but I'm like again, I was like in this triangle where
like okay, if I don't have the baby, things can still move forward
cuz it's like it's like we can still figure out if we're compatible,
we can still figure [laughter] all that that out and yeah, I
don't Again, if I don't think if the pregnancy happened, I don't
think any of this would happen but sorry, go
That's not actually so true, too, is it? He's getting through
that bottle pretty quick as well. Go ahead. I don't know. I
always [clears throat] told you that come out would have preferred.
But I told you I would support you regardless and I'd be there
for you. And I think I tried to show up both emotionally and
physically by being there in person. I think I went out of my
way to try to make that clear to you. And also didn't lie to
you. I didn't tell you I'm going to be fine, everything's going
to be great. I said I told you it's going to be tough on us,
it's going to be tough on you, it's going to be tough on me.
I don't know how many changes afterwards. I can only tell you
that I'm dreading it. And I think that's a reasonable and like
mature response to the whole situation. And I don't need anyone
to coddle me or anything like that. I know these things are going
to be difficult and who knows, maybe this breaks us. Who knows?
But I would never force you to parenthood before you're ready
and I always told you that. So what I'm saying there is because
she didn't want to have the kid and I was saying I did, right?
I told you there like I'm not going to sit here and convince
you to be a parent. I think that's weird. Like I can't force
someone to be a parent. So if I'm having a kid with
Abba is not
is that not an all-party consent country for phone calls? No,
Canada is single-party, one-party consent. >> And I'm the
one who wants it, they don't want it. I'm not going to force
them into parenthood. So I told her what I felt and then I stopped.
I stopped trying to convince her to keep the kid. She don't want
to keep it. So I was >> Also, I'm pretty confident all
basically all international calls are one-party consent, I think.
I'm pretty sure. I >> it and tried to be supportive but
I was in this really weird position. So, I'll keep going. Always.
And I understand you may or may not felt that way, but I didn't
need you to know from my perspective like I really tried to convey
to you what I wanted while letting you know that I would have
your back to the best of my abilities. Whatever you choose.
And I understand you might have felt differently. I'm just saying
what I said and what I tried to do in terms of actions. Okay?
Right? Cuz you you didn't you didn't want me there for the abortion.
Remember?
Uh-huh. I had to convince you.
It's a 33-minute call he's got recorded. He's playing a small
section of it. >> wanted to be there for it. And I Here's
the thing, when you have something like this, the best thing
to do is not
Basically, no matter what. Unless she's accusing you of like
a crime essentially or something that's like going to totally
sour your career, you don't respond. Cuz now you're playing this
a tiny section of a 33-minute call and all anyone's going to
say is what's on the rest of that call?
Like what are you what are you doing with the rest of that call?
You keep doing these like selective pieces of information. You
drop these selective pieces and you can never get out of the
hole with people unless you make your whole life available.
There's just no reason to ever start.
And I don't know who's not telling him this. If he doesn't have
friends who could tell him this, it's it's just uh it's tough.
It's tough to watch. >> Okay, here we go. I wrote a bunch
of notes. I take some L's. You know what I mean? Your boy's not
against admitting his faults. Uh Abba chose her. That's a big
time L. All right? That's on me. Whatever she's doing right now
at the end of the day I chose her, so that's on me. Uh Abba ignored
some red flags. That's a big time L. Okay? And I will tell you
guys why. Before she got pregnant, I think. I thought I'd break
up with her one time and she brought me back in, but at the end
of the day I allowed myself to get brought back in. So, before
any of this crazy [__] happened, Abba's going to
hold the L cuz he ignored some big ass red flags that he saw,
decided to ignore cuz he said we're going to work through it.
And I think this is one of those times where I'm like working
through it is not bad. Just don't do it for the wrong person.
And Abba needed an L for that. >> And you're never going
to be able to make that call. You basically
Man, that's a that's a tough one. You kind of have to try to
work through some stuff and like commit. And if you don't, if
you like try to say try to tell yourself you're going to know
when it's going to work out if you work through it, it's never
going to you're you're going to never make the decision to actually
work through stuff. >> Um I would didn't leave when he
felt it was time. That's another L. Three times total, okay?
Uh another L. I got her pregnant. I'm also messaging that with
my doc. My doc lied to me, okay? And uh the sixth one And this
is the one that I think I'm probably most accountable for. I
would engage in fights that she started when he should have walked
away. Now, I'm talking in third person cuz I wrote that in my
notes, but that's what I did, okay? There were some arguments
that we had that she
Look at you, spread all these if she want to go there. But she
would initiate these things and she she She had a habit of like
pushing this button. And I was like, "Yo, you tripping." And
then she would push it and then I would retaliate and then she
would "I would never. How could you say that?" It I can't tell
y'all how much that [__] is triggering, but to be
involved with somebody you can't walk away from
Is this the Myron Gaines button? Is this the Myron Gaines button
where she's like, "I'm going to I'm going to send this conversation
to Myron right now." I feel like I do feel like that's what I'm
hearing. Is that it's the Myron Gaines button. That's like the
threat she makes consistently. That's why cuz she said one time
that she was going to do that. >> your [__]
buttons and then you say something and they act like they never
did nothing. I remember I even sent her a message one time and
I I started like cataloging at some point what the tactics felt
like every time we would have a disagreement. And I'm going to
I'm going to show it to you guys cuz this is like from our own
threads. I actually sent it to her to be like, "I know this is
going to happen." And you know what's crazy? After I would send
it to her, I'm like, "All right, here's a fight about to start."
I would send her this message be like, "This is what I think
is going to happen. One of these four. Let's see which one happen."
I swear she would start hitting one, two, three like it was bingo.
Okay, so this is what it was.
So, here it was. It would go complain about how you feel without
understanding how the other feels, okay? Downplay your part in
all of it. Number three, frame yourself as the wrong party in
every discussion. Number four, pretend to be accountable, but
end everything with yet I was wrong, but you were more wrong.
I'm not going to sit here and say she was more wrong or I was
less wrong, okay? That is always going to be subjective or whatever.
But when you have two people have an argument and both do something
wrong, saying you were What the [__] is your name
on there? It's probably Well, what is this? You know what I'm
saying? It seems pointless like trying to tally up these things.
It just feels like everything you say afterwards is because you're
always positioning yourself as the person who's aggrieved and
the other one's the aggressor and they need to like really be,
you know, apologizing. Every argument we would have would be
one of these four. And it just got so exhausting. And at one
point, I just stopped. I literally would not talk. It it be we
need to like afterwards is What was wrong with her? Let me go
back to this cuz he's saying, "Okay, every time she did one of
these things, okay, frame yourself as the wrong party in every
discussion." That will happen if you ever have unresolved tension
of any kind. Somebody will be angry at you for like multiple
reasons and then basically like you'll get in a fight and they'll
they'll basically be angry over something else and they will
feel like the wrong party. And so basically that can happen in
every relationship every single time. Downplay your part in all
of it. I mean, that's what everybody does in every argument.
It's like you basically give I hate I hate this thing. If somebody
gives you like a system that you use or something and it's like,
"Well, things everybody does in every argument ever."
Like things that happen in every relationship ever. That's the
system. Okay. You You're going to Hey Abba, you're going to be
a black man in every argument we have. Yeah, I I read you like
a book. It's like, "No, you didn't."
You you just said something that was obviously going to happen.
>> It seems pointless. Like trying to tally up these things
it just feels like everything you say afterwards is because you're
always positioning yourself as the person who's aggrieved and
the other one is the aggressor and they need to like I just It
was the It was the thing that was on the surface. That's all.
>> apologizing. Every argument we would have That's it.
Would be one of these four. And it just got so exhausting. And
at one point I just stopped. I literally would not talk. Because
every disagreement that we would have would end up in one of
these four. And I was like, "I'm tired." Now you guys are hearing
all this and you're like, "Abba, why would you ever stay?" Cuz
like I said, you guys are hearing now the negative side. But
there's actually a good side to her. She can be very kind. She
can be very caring. She can be very thoughtful. In fact,
this backpack is a gift she got me which I'm a big fan of. She
She got me the AirPods I'm using right now. She
We'd be very Listen, I'm not going to get all things but she's
I'm not here to position her as like some gold digger thing.
Like she never asked me for money even though I spent way more
in terms of traveling and stuff like that. But um Yeah, there
was a lot of good times.
I honestly think that if there was no pregnancy, I don't know
how things would have gone. Okay? But unfortunately it did happen
and it Like a pregnancy just accelerates everything. It changes
the whole dynamic. It just does. So,
you know,
to me more than anything, this all this is just sad. It's unnecessary
to me. But, let's keep going. All right, I see
Yeah, I
essentially everything you say to be vulnerable or to be honest
is going to be weaponized and that's the unfortunate thing, man.
It's He just didn't I I don't know how he didn't have somebody
who messaged him who's just like, "Bro, you got to You got to
not do that, okay? Just take a day. Just take a day. I know it
feels like a lot to take a full day, but just take a day, breathe,
figure out what you want to say,
prepare something
more time than this. More time than this. Is a horrible response?
It's like the expected response, but I'm just looking at it from
like a content creator point of view, how other content creators
are going to use it against That's why it's not a good response.
Also, he's like because he's so all over the place, I think she'll
have more responses as
And yeah, he implied she was cheating and and then he goes back
and forth like, Oh, well, she's not even like such a bad person.
She texts me and she goes,
"You're out of the pregnancy. I'm going to handle this by yourself
since you haven't messaged me back. Um, you're out." So, first
off, I'm like, "Since when do you want to keep this thing?" One,
two, "Since when do you cut me out?" Like, so I text her, very
calmly, I'm like, "Yo, calm down. You don't do that." She starts
going off and then I calm her down. We get on a call. We start
smoothing things over. But, now my anxiety is a bit up because
I'm like, this woman's going willy-nilly say I'm not in it anymore,
which is a crazy thing to experience. Fast forward some time
and um for me, this is like a point where I'm starting to think
like, maybe I don't want to be involved with her in any shape,
way, or form. Because not only because she constantly changed
her mind on me, but she can tell me I'm not part of things whenever
she wants to. She thinks that's acceptable. She didn't just also
tell me that she also canceled all of her plans. Called canceled
her Christmas plans or New New Year's plans. I was like, "Yo."
And your boy Jaden. From there, she gets very upset with me considering
ending things between the two of us. Yeah, and then this could
be this there's a chess match going on, okay? These two people
trying to win the breakup. There's a chess match going on. She
She did her first move. Now she's letting Aba make a move. Myron
wanted to wait. He's waiting back He's waiting to watch the stream
before he makes a move. There's a lot of different players. There's
a lot of different chess matches going on at the same time. >> over
here. Okay. Boom. Okay.
Now, if you guys are wondering why it's written like this, it's
because this is a voice memo that I recorded that I turned into
a note to share with her some of the feelings that I've been
feeling, okay? So, I'm going to read that out to you guys. It
says
This can't be good, man. You can't Ah! And for me, you know,
one thing that's important is anytime I do bring a child into
the world, I'm actively part of their life. That means that I'm
seeing them on a regular basis and that I'm very close to their
mother, ideally married. That's the best situation for me and
that we are together. That's what I truly truly want. My biggest
fear is that I have the opposite of that, that if I end up What
I want to say there is that if I end up in a situation with Dizzin,
I can't spend time with my kid and there's a separation of sorts,
that prospect terrifies me, okay? And the reason I bring that
is that the deepest parts of myself there are some parts of you
that are worried or are a bit nervous that you are still very
much on the fence, that you aren't very certain, which at this
stage isn't even an abnormal thing. And the reason I'm saying
that is like, >> we aren't deep enough into our dating
journey for her to be certain about me,
So, I can understand and especially being pregnant, hormonal,
you know, I'm seeing it from her perspective, I can understand
why she might be on the fence about the relationship still, okay?
Okay. Which at this stage isn't even abnormal. But the potential
outcome of us bringing this child and then you realizing this
only afterwards terrifies the [__] out of me. I want
to bring it up to you because I'm not just mentioning this out
of the blue. I'm going to skip ahead a little bit
Oh, what was >> to bring it up to you because I'm not just
mentioning this out of the blue. Trending searches. Connor McDavid.
Okay, okay. So, something else.
Vegas handbrake. Uh I just I was curious if there'd be anything
here. Facebook via me via my ex. I'm going to skip ahead a little
bit here. No cool leaks. Nothing at all. I do feel over the time
that we've known each other that you've brought up a lot of problems
that you have with me, be it the way I run my personal stuff.
That would actually be really funny, man. Uh where's where's
the pickle? I think I think it was the pickle who messaged Daisy
if I'm not mistaken. I think the pickle started reaching out
to Daisy. That's who it was right off the >> talk my judgment,
you know, um you self-relating to my past quite a lot and yes,
you moved past it. So, for more context, she's like mentioned,
okay, I'm not trying to build a fire. She would bring up a lot
of problems. Some of them I felt were very ridiculous, personally.
And some of the stuff she should have known before she got with
me. And someone saying like, "I have a problem with your past."
is a weird thing to say, considering like I am who I am publicly.
So, why would you come out all of a sudden and say that to me?
Or like, my sense of humor or things like that. Like it's just
like, "Lady, you're like you're going to do this now?" But, she
had issues. You're entitled to those. My main issue is you are
here now, and here at the 11th hour you want to bring up stuff
that you should have known beforehand. So, then why are you doing
that? But, it's her right. I'm saying essentially if you have
these problems, and we have this kid, and it's irreconcilable.
That's an issue for me, okay?
But, I just want you to understand that the mounting of things
that I felt like I've been cutting up that have become sources
of issues for us makes me wonder if you're simultaneously both
loving me and at the same time not sure if I'm the man for you.
And as far as I'm being asked to change some aspects of myself
and some very core to me, I worry that some of these are irreconcilable
differences. And yeah, my concern is bringing a kid into that
situation. It's a bit scary. So, I wanted to kind of just share
that with you what I'm thinking. And yeah, I can I can handle
you not wanting me. I can't handle having a child with you and
then finding that out. There you go. Okay, you guys can see it
there on the screen. And I think that's a fair statement. You
know, my thing wasn't the fear of being co-parents. Guys, relationships
get together, they break up sometimes. That's okay. That I think
Here's the thing. He's putting this stuff out there. I get the
feeling that before the first abortion or something, that he
was like
a good person. Like like she had no problems with who he was.
It didn't seem like she made any, you know, she Not that she
had no problems. She She The way she presented it was he had
There was differences, possibly irreconcilable irreconcilable
differences. But, she didn't think he was like being an or monster
before the first abortion like attempt. That's That wasn't what
she thought. It sounded like they were dating for 5 months when
she found out she was pregnant. July 2025,
so that's December of 2025.
And that's like when they had this discussion. I get a call from
her. Can we talk? Immediately at the middle of the day. And so,
I'm like, "Hmm." She's like, "Do you think you can come home
and we'll talk then?" Like whatever inside of me felt off, okay?
I said no and I'll leave, which I never do. But, I mean, this
is the this is the future mother of my children, the person I'm
supposed to be married to. I don't know. Like So, I go home,
I get on the I want to say that I maybe said five words and she
did most of the talking. And you know what I'm going to say guys?
There's nothing worse than when someone breaks up with you, okay?
And they want to say a bunch of compliments. It is the most exhausting
thing. So, you busy getting this over with.
That's true.
And then they the worst part is and then they get offended when
you're like, "Yeah, I'm good. Bye." Like, right?
That's happened That's happened to me before. He's like, "Oh,
we we got to break up." And I'm like, "Yeah, we both know we've
had to break up." And they're like, "But, I really appreciate
every Yeah, shut up. I don't care. I'm out. I'm out." And they're
like, "You're such an a Yeah, well, you don't have to deal with
it anymore. Bye. >> I said it in the voice message, right?
The the voice note you guys saw before. I can handle you not
wanting me. I can't handle you not wanting me after the child
is here. Yeah. So, I said, "I can handle you not wanting me.
I can't handle having a child with you and then finding that
out. Cool."
Up until now, she never wanted a kid. She tried to have multiple
abortions,
Tell me how this lady gets on a call with me and says, "I'm ending
the relationship and I'm keeping the baby." Oh, [__]
That's really crazy to do. She That's really That's insane to
hit the Don DeMarco, okay? Dude, yeah, yeah. She She told me
that SHE WANTED TO BREAK UP WITH ME AND KEEP THE BABY?
DUDE, I OKAY.
IT'S A SERIOUS SITUATION, MAN. It's a serious situation. Look,
I
Yo, when I say I was floored.
I For a guy who never wanted to make his personal life like like
he never wanted to publicize it at all, he sure is like totally
fine with playing it up as much as possible on a stream. It's
a little weird, right?
You're trying to just with him a child support? Even he doesn't
think that. That's a weird way >> I didn't say a word.
I was so blown
I was this real life? The all all the And now And and and I literally
never saw it coming. She never spoke to me. Never gave me a heads-up.
And I'll prove it to you guys, okay? You don't worry. There's
proof. Oh, when just when you guys had like been talking less,
when you were like out dancing, when you were having like problems
in general, she picked the like one thing that you said you never
wanted to have happen. Oh my god. I Who Who could have possibly
seen this coming? Who could have possibly seen this coming?
She's already made it public? Yeah, she did. I'm telling you
that it's weird to be totally ready when you're uncomfortable
with your personal life being out there. Like totally ready to
turn that all into jokes for a stream. That's me personally.
Hey.
>> It is what it is. >> to wait. And then I'll tell
you what she said. And she was giving me a speech. Oh, you were
so amazing. You're the best. Blah blah blah blah blah blah And
I don't Okay. Peep this. Peep this. >> He's almost done.
And my first reaction, I'm still in shock cuz this is the one
outcome I asked her not for.
And she blindsided me with it.
>> And I said, "Okay. Just uh keep me
And you guys might think that reaction is crazy, but having her
cut me out already a couple times, for her to do that this way,
and for the kid thing to be dropped that way, was insanity. I
can't tell you this is by far the
Yeah, I think he's lying here. I think he's I think he's bluff
calling. I think he I think he's like egotistical. I think he
thought, "Oh, you're going to have the baby and not talk to me?"
Yeah, off. Yeah, I know that's not true. I feel like that's a
bluff call. Right? I feel like that's a bluff call, and then
he distances, and he might have been correct in his bluff call,
but that's what he was doing there, right? He goes, "You know
what? I think you're [__] with I think you're just
trying to say the thing that I told you was the worst possible
thing. I'm going to let you go like a flapping in the wind, okay?
Like a flag in the unsecured flag in the wind. You're going to
flap around in the wind, you." Oh, is that Breach?
Oh, you want to jump in? They They thought you hated me. Were
you listening the whole time? Dude, this is this I He is like
a little manic. They thought you hated me. Nobody thought that.
Come on, man. Nobody thought that. Be serious.
Nobody thought that at all.
Uh Preach needs to Dude, I Preach has to be such a genius to
somehow land this plane with no casualties, okay? He is He is
suddenly stepping into the cockpit of a plane. The pilots have
have died, okay? He's stepping into the cockpit. The plane has
no landing gear. It's down two engines. And he has to land this
plane somehow. It would take a level of
unparalleled in this universe to land this plane with zero casualties
cuz somehow he's got to get this shut down. He's got to get it
slowed down. And we're not going to leak anything else, but he
can't make Aba look manic or
So, how will he do it? How can he do it? I have no idea. I have
no idea. How is it? Good job. Okay. Good job. This is the I was
an hour and a half away from here. Yeah, yeah. She She said she
said when Preach finds out he's going to leave. I was like, "You're
stupid as [__] [__] Yeah, you're stupid
as fuck." I'm sorry. Let me shut that off cuz
I do By the way, I do know Preach will be on his side cuz they're
business partners. I'm sorry. If basic Imagine you had a company
that was making like millions of dollars for you and the co-founder
of the company is like, "I need you to come and support me or
else we could possibly lose like a lot of this revenue." Yeah,
you're going to come in. This is my guy. I believe in this guy
no matter what. THIS IS MY GUY ALWAYS. It's ride or die, okay?
It's not the Aba show or the Preach show. It's not going to do
anywhere near as well as the Aba and Preach show. So, like this
isn't even really an indication of anything that Preach is here.
It's Preach has to be here. Preach will be here to make sure
this doesn't get to explode. I left I was an hour and a half
away from here. Yeah. I was on stage at I left at 8:15. 9:03.
[laughter]
He sprinted into the building. To get an idea of where where
Preach's head is at. He's out of breath as he gets here. He's
out of breath. He sprinted into the [__] building.
>> I You know how You know cuz you said you wanted to do
this tomorrow, but I'm like, "You know this can't wait. I want
to go and do this." I didn't know that's what you I didn't know
I didn't understand that's what you were doing. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I realized I put the dots together, one and one together.
And I was like, "Oh, shit." It is that. All right, cool. You
thought you took the whole spot. You moved on >> Cuz I
was going to do some dancing. I set up the camera. I was going
to do some dancing later. We was going to do a little session.
All right. So, I'll keep going from that.
Bring your He did bring his sweet shoes. Oh, boy. >> some
dancing later. We was going to do a little session. All right.
So, I'll keep going from that.
I told him the same thing I told you. Are you good? Yeah, to
be honest, I'm actually good. I know, bro, but I'm just I know
I appreciate you. A couple of boys hit me up. I said, "Listen,
guys, >> boys, listen." >> you. I didn't know it.
So, it was for me the worst betrayal, to be honest. And I'll
[__] own up to this. It's not a responsible thing
to respond the way that I did. But I hope you guys understand
the shock that I had in the moment. And with a few months, I
might have changed in my mind. To be honest with you, co-parenting
with someone like her, I just can't imagine it. She is a The
way she handled this whole situation was demonic, okay?
I'll still defend her in a lot of regards, but I'm glad Like,
one of the most happy parts, guys, like, the reason why I can
smile today is like I just stop all this drama is I don't got
to co-parent with her. You know what I'm saying? I don't got
to be tethered to this person for the rest of my life. I will
be a Dude, I I could just, man, could you imagine if she faked
the abortion? Could you just Could you
That would be That would elevate this to like drama of the year
immediately.
Yes. Yeah, I know he's manic coping. Yeah, I know he's manic.
I know he's coping. He's not actually okay. He's two drinks in.
Dude, Ab's whole brand is he is nonchalant. He is totally fine
with like everything. And he showed up and started getting drunk
on a stream.
crazy.
That's so outside the brand
And now he's telling us how he's he's really okay and like how
Actually, he's just psyched that he's like gone, she's gone,
he's not to do anything.
Oh my.
Even Even Preach don't believe it. Even Preach is a little sus.
Even Preach is like, "Eh, you being for real right now? Eh, I
don't know about this one, man. I don't know. I don't know, man."
eternally grateful for that. I'm sad about other parts. There's
some things I'm mourning. But just imagine how crazy all this
is, and you guys are going to do your clips on mine. Go crazy.
I ain't going to trip, but at the end of the day At the end of
the day? I'm okay. What do you want to >> No, I'm just
waiting for the juicy part.
Okay, then the point where I get to call her a witch.
when she hears that I don't want anything to do with her, initially
she's like, "Cool, bye." Few then. I [clears throat] block her
ass cuz I'm like, "You've betrayed me, so [__] you."
Right? I didn't say that literally, but I'm like, "Be gone out
of my life,
Tell me how Wait. I start getting bombarded by everyone in her
circle with blackmail threats. What? Why do you
We can speculate, but So, this piece of
I thought she was nice. Not in this moment. She's a garbage right
now. People shift. People go through phases. I was a garbage
in my younger years. You hear me? Okay. I'm mad at you right
now. So, she had sent me a recording that she had done of our
call. I didn't know she was recording. So, you guys I I need
you to Maybe normal online is not normal to me. I've never had
someone record a call with me. And then she had uploaded it to
YouTube in a private account, and she sent me the fact that she
recorded our final The one where I was really upset about.
>> I KNEW THIS IS WHAT IT WAS CUZ THIS IS THE BLACKMAIL
THREAT, RIGHT? And this is where it's going to pop that she threatened
to send it to my mom, right?
was Okay? This is it. >> say whatever you want about that
call. You played I don't I don't feel bad at all. The betrayal
I felt at that time and how she could do that to me after everything
I tried, I was like, "Yo, [__] you." She recorded
it. I was blown away. That's why I have the recordings I have
now cuz when I realized she was recording she was trying to build
some kind of case, I said, "I'm going to keep my recordings from
the future going forward. Okay?"
So, she sends me texts. I don't
I said, "I'm going to keep my Dude, I got to watch this Preach.
I got to watch Preach react to this. You do that to me after
everything I tried, I was like, "Yo, [__] you." She
recorded it. I was blown Dude, am I am I >> the only one
seeing this? Am I the only one seeing Preach right now? Preach
is trying to be a good soldier, okay? He's trying to be He's
trying to stay calm. He's trying to like remain uh even keel
even keel.
And it's not going great. >> That's why I have the recordings
I have now cuz when I realized she was recording is trying to
build some kind of case, I said, I'm going to keep my recordings
from the future going forward, okay?
So she says to me text Dude, I I don't engage. I block her. She
sends it from a different number sending me the link to the video.
And do you guys see what it says here? Video one of Okay? Dude,
Filipina and nurse man, I'm sorry. There were a lot of red flags
there. And I'm going to read the text that she sent me. The text
says,
"I told him to release it." You know what I said? "Release it.
I don't care. Genuinely, I don't run my life in a way that if
it became public I'm terrified. I told her, "Release it. It's
worth having you out of my life." Let's see if I got more of
this [__]
Then her friend started messaging me. Look what this goober ass
posted. Y'all see this? Phone number, the phone number, the phone
number. I don't care. [__] the phone [__]
the phone number [__] the phone Oh god, he's putting
her phone number out here. Oh boy.
phone number phone number phone number PHONE NUMBER. I'LL GIVE
A I WILL DOX YOUR STUPID I'LL GIVE A OKAY. ALL RIGHT. Very very
very cool. Definitely not manic. Definitely doing okay. This
is why I just told you guys from the very beginning
Uh you did not take enough time to do this. You did not take
enough time to put [__] together. And this is going
to go badly. And here it is. Sure enough, here it is. It's going
badly. >> [__] phone number. You see this?
So she's like, "Yo, I'm going to contact Dude, preach. Preach's
face.
Preach's face, man.
Oh, he knows. Oh boy. I'm sorry with the number. Like honestly,
the number's not going to be that big a deal here. Hey Myron,
my friend is dating Abba and oh my god, she wrote the text in.
She wrote the text in, too. Hey Myron, my friend is dating Abba
and    Feddy reacts.
Dude. Ops. I want y'all to think how crazy that is. I want y'all
to think about how crazy that is. Someone you trusted, someone
you loved, someone you gave everything to, and they had their
friends say they were going to blackmail you by contacting the
ops. Now from her perspective, what she's going to say is, "I
felt abandoned. She abandoned me first. You gave me the one outcome
I didn't ask. And then you cut me out. And then in a 24-hour
span, you were asking me to be supportive of you. You had to
be like, 'Okay, so how are we going to co-parent?'" That is a
crazy thing to do. Now she's hormonal, she's losing it. I'm going
to be as charitable as I can be and say it's probably not easy
on her end, but this is insane. Ain't it? Is it before or after
she had she contacted me? This is before.
Here's another one here, a different person. And what I said
I said feel She would never, but her friends will. She said her
friends to go AFTER ME,
OH,
NO.
He doxxed her friend. So, he doxxed her
And Preach just grabbed the drink. >> Before or after she
had she contacted me? Crazy thing to do. Now, she's hormonal,
she's losing it. I'm going to be as charitable He did grab the
drink and move it over. Oh, get this one out of here. I'll get
this one out of here. Maybe no more Maybe no more soju for Mr.
Albi here. >> it's probably not easy on her end, but this
is insane. And [snorts] I'm going to go pretty early and you're
going to hear quite a lot of recording. Again, I only started
recording after I realized she tried to blackmail me. That's
the only time, okay? That's okay. Uh thank you for letting me
say all of that. Yeah. So, the context right now, the reason
why she's like this is that she had called me. Eventually, she
had apologized. She apologized cuz she knew she was tripping
and she admitted that she was mostly at fault, okay? During this
apology call that she does, okay? A lot else gets said, but this
is her after I'd responded to her apology call, okay? I don't
know if it was like two texts. I I don't remember cuz a lot of
it is hazy. I just remember she had a lengthy apology for everything
that she did that was wrong.
I think just to
debrief or to recap, I uh yeah, I couldn't have you I don't want
you to to for us to separate and you not think that this was
>> yeah, really hard on me. Um and that I didn't love you.
Again, I don't think the amount of um like grief I had gone through
this last would have existed and like uh still carry that. I
I don't think he's crying, but he is getting the sniffles. I
don't know. Today, um [laughter] I feel like the pregnancy kind
of made me not think correctly and do things the right way and
um it kind of messed things up weirdly and I didn't move properly
and the only thing I can say to that is like I didn't know what
I was doing and I was I was honestly
Preach Preach is trying to calculate. He's like got the numbers
going through his head. He's like, "Wait."
Very, very standard. Very, very standard stuff going on here.
What am I supposed to take away from
That she was a apologize sheep. She's literally saying it was
the pregnancy hormones. I understand like you can't blame everything
on that, but like that's what she's saying. What are we What
are we trying to do here? And the only thing I can say to that
is like I didn't know what I was I bet you I bet you what she
did was not just say that he was she wasn't going to be with
him. I bet you this is where the idea of cheating comes in or
something. I was I was honestly trying my best. And uh Sorry
guys, you can hear me clicking in the background. I'm I'm doing
the same pose I did when she broke up with me. Yeah. Um I'm sorry
for everything. It's okay. Like I said earlier when before we
started this call, I don't want you to think that I want to do
this to have a chance to litigate the past or prove my point.
I really want to just want you to be able to say what you want
to say and take things off your chest. And [snorts] I appreciate
you sharing all these things and and uh yeah, I Do you have any
questions that you want to ask me? No, but I think
really the only honest thing that I'm feeling right now is like
you're not saying much and that's uh just making me feel dumb
for like saying everything that I said. What?
My boy, I'm a Sorry, apologies. She's mad because I didn't reply
in the week he needed to. So, now she regrets her apology. Preach
got the empty. Preach got the empty. He didn't get the full one.
He got the empty. My boy, I'm going to tell you something right
now, okay? >> And it might be controversial, but I don't
think so.
In my lifetime,
I've seen many
many pregnant women. And I can tell you that much.
>> The pregnancy is not the problem.
>> It's something else. Based on that call?
Preach Preach is This is what I'm talking about. This is like
he's infinitely supportive, right? It's based on that call. A
woman crying to be like, "I really [__] up. I shouldn't
have said that. Pregnancy hormones are making me crazy." I've
never seen I've never seen a pregnant woman do anything like
that before. Yeah. Yeah, huh? Okay. That's why I'm not I'm not
That's right there. I just I stopped engaging cuz every time
I would disagree, it was always like you're more wrong, and my
feelings was always like, you know what? Cool. I just stopped
talking. And that's what you're seeing right there, okay? I am
going to move the recording along.
>> I'm going to now explain to her why I pulled away, and
you guys are going to hear her reaction, okay? I didn't see any
of that coming. You know, um I also spent time thinking about
it. I mean, as far as the end you know, I just didn't see any
of that coming, and I kind of just didn't [clears throat] say
anything at the time obviously I was very caught off guard, and
on top of that, it was like an outcome I never could have ever
So, you know, with the shock and everything, all I wanted was
to just kind of get away, and I understand that
from your perspective, you might have felt like you needed me,
but honestly, I felt like you was ran a truck over to my
And I didn't want to say anything cuz I had no control or any
say in it. So, it was just like
I just couldn't be supportive. I couldn't be there for you
>> cuz I was just uh yeah, I don't Yeah, I Yeah, I knew
I knew I did that to you. Um Yeah, and and and I'll just say
like you know, I don't know. My response wasn't great, but
you know, it it felt like I got ran over, and then I was like
asked to be supportive and present by the person who ran me over,
and when I just kept wanting to like get away, like I was just
bombarded. And so then I just started attacking. And by bombarded,
I mean I was harassed by all her friends and burned in black
mail. Not proud of that response, but
Then I just started attacking. Okay. >> I could have done
in that moment when I tried to get away, you know, like And [snorts]
I'm I'm really not someone who spends time being cool to the
people around them or stuff like that. I'm actually a generally
very very very calm. But I definitely felt like
Yeah, but I don't I just I felt like there was not much space
for me throughout quite a lot of it. And
And [clears throat] uh I know you're hearing me a little bit
emotional. Feel
Yeah, I I knew It's okay. I I know you know about
>> And um I'm sorry that I kept like trying to reach out.
Um I'm not saying this is right. I was so desperate to figure
out like Well, I knew that at that point we were just like at
war, and we were just fighting. Um but like I just was so desperate
to figure out what to do with the pregnancy and me wanting to
keep it and then me have I had broken up with you because I wanted
to keep it but then that was like a dumb thing [laughter] that
I did. Again, I froze and
the end of the way that ended I'm not saying it's right I'm just
telling you like it was like I don't even know what the heck
I got [clears throat] my my like cognitive ability was just like
so impaired by all this pressure and um yeah and then that again
that's why I reached out to Peach and I was just so desperate
to figure it out and do the right thing and it was like soul
crushing like this whole thing did like [laughter] just hit like
my heart like it crushed my spirit like everything did uh like
from the moment you know we even like me after we told you um
and me like not realizing like everything happened so quick and
even like a few weeks after I knew it was my fault but like I
was like I knew you were going through like your process of like
shock in the beginning but like it like it was the week I had
the abortion and um Kim really had came back to help me um and
like this was 2 weeks after talking to you after our last talk
and um [clears throat] yeah it was actually it was 2 weeks after
I was still trying to figure out if I wanted the baby um I I
had gone through like a weird shock She was so shocked her first
reaction was to rent a Fresh N' Fit anyone else any To be honest
with you guys that's like to me so insane. I've never had a problem
with someone so severe.
I don't She's literally talking about a friend who came over.
I Has she admitted to messaging Fresh N' Fit or to trying to
go to them or that she was even the person doing it? I actually
don't I don't know. But I'm like I'm going to blackmail you or
I'm going to contact your biggest enemy and tell them a secret
I think is going to destroy you. Like that's so god damn corny.
Even And to someone you love like you know you guys hear me here.
I don't talk about her like she's the devil she definitely She
said she didn't she just threatened it. Okay, she did Okay. Well
oh wait she already said she said she talked about messaging
she mentioned messaging Myron Gaines. She said that in her video
right? But that's still but I was with someone I loved before
cuz we went through something difficult genuinely. I'm still
mourning
the abortion and everything that happened with it. It's a tough
thing for me. I don't know I haven't so I'm going to have to
figure that out that's my own experience. But there's just certain
things that she did and she just doesn't recognize the gravity
of it or what kind of betrayal it is. Go ahead. She told me something
that was very interesting. You guys remember how she presented
herself as first Christian woman very demure or very chill. Oh
oh uh-oh. She said to me You know you like you see her Instagram
like you're very chill. So like this is the perfect She would
never court the attention of other men. If another man approaches
her, blah blah blah all this other stuff. She was like overcompensating
and she was very territorial and jealous. And to give you guys
some context
If you guys go to my Instagram, I follow like 43 people, okay?
Most of them dancers or artists or my family members. >> But
not me. Not him. Yeah. >> Cuz you're not an artist, a family
member or
So or friend. So You know how funny The reason why my ex-wife
is really important this part, okay? Cuz you're going to start
to see my reaction why. When you believe someone, you believe
them for who they present themselves. This girl one time she
got mad at me cuz I was following this like random dancing
Oh my god, is he Is he doing the MisGif thing? Are him and MisGif
the same guy? That like you break up and you're like and then
she posts something that's like she's wearing like a certain
kind of outfit and you're like, you stupid
I thought you weren't a I thought you weren't a
That can't be it, right? There's no way. It's got to be something
pointed where she tries to get his attention like directly through
DMs. If it's just an Instagram post with her in a certain outfit
or dancing with some guys or some
I feel like this guy might be cooked, okay? We'll see. >> like
a lot of tutorials and stuff in regards to bachata. I like this
stuff. I like watching people. I'm a very someone who practices
dance technically. >> You like bachata? No, but her footsteps
She did Dominican bachata. Yeah, never mind. She did Dominican.
>> No, Dominican bachata is different. >> was fire.
>> I'm a Haitian man giving props to the Dominican for
the bachata. I got to give him. Peep it. >> The the yeah.
Peep it. Yeah. Yeah. I like watching. I don't post comments.
I don't like posts. I'm not somebody who's on Instagram thirsty.
To me that's I just don't do it. She'd gone through my follow
list and had issue cuz I was following one or two dancers and
I was I appreciated the fact that they were very gifted. But
these very talented dancers.
>> They were very gifted. Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay. you gay.
All right, they're very gifted. In what ways were they gifted?
Precious knows that's that's a lot of cope right there, bro.
That's a lot of cope right there.
Why am I laughing? The whole time this lady had a Facebook Instagram,
but she was like following hundreds of dudes, okay? Again, I
just don't care. I mean, the hypocrisy pissed me off and annoyed
me, but I actually didn't I wasn't threatened, okay?
So, there's this >> Because none of the dudes are role
related. True. I don't know there's a problem. All right, Rico,
we can't let him get in. He can always slide in, roll through,
and then you know Peep it. >> Uh-huh. So, this lady tells
me while we were still talking and she was trying to reconcile
things and get back together, even though I felt off. She was
telling me she loved me, she wanted to be with me, she really
thought like things would work with me, blah blah blah. And I
was like, you know, and I I I I I'm not going to say like she
was one-sided, but part of me was just I was always reluctant.
And that's why you can see the text at the end where I'm like,
I don't think we can do this.
She tells me that she has a product she's doing and it's getting
popular. She's like, has this Instagram where she's showcasing
her skills or whatever. And [snorts] I'm like, well, what kind
of stuff you posting on there?
You okay? This is where she lies. She's like, oh, you know, it's
mostly like archery stuff.
It's like it's not it's not like a the thirst trap kind. I was
like, cool.
It's not? Uh-huh.
So, tell me after we stopped talking, tell me why
I see this come across my feed. Yeah, that's what it is. Oh,
no, BUDDY. OH, NO.
OH, NO. He sees He sees a thirst trap. He's like, "This stupid
s-
>> There's no way. Please, Alba. Don't be that guy. Don't
be that guy in this moment. Don't be that You're going to give
Myron the biggest W on planet Earth if this is the only thing
that happened. You You can't You cannot do it.
But it's it What? No, go ahead. No, these posts that she was
making were during the time
that she was trying to get us back and she said we were supposed
to make it work. Right. Peep it. But after you guys had broken
up. You were broken up, right? Oh, boy.
Let me see here.
You By the way, she probably was doing it intentionally to get
your attention. Like that's probably true.
I'm not even joking. That is almost certainly true, man.
Oh, he's about to show the post. I think he's about to show them.
All right, here it is. Okay. Now, look at this. That's not Oh,
no. There's got to be something worse than this, right? There's
got to be something more than this.
Her second account she had That's her That's the the account
Mind you, this account she never showed Bro, that's got to be
Hold on. Hold on. Wait, wait, wait. Go back. Holly Lee Kalian.
Hold on. Is that already Is someone archive? Does anybody have
the ability to archive here? That's what I'm looking for.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. >> account
she had That's her That's the the account Mind you, this account
she never showed me. I'd ask her she would never show it. She
refused. I was like, "Why are you hiding this account?" She's
like, "I just don't feel comf- But she's like, "You know, I'm
trying things and >> feel comfortable showing some I I
know why she didn't show me. It is It's It's already private,
isn't
I think it's already private, isn't it?
Come on.
Me? You You don't feel comfortable showing some [__]
to someone that you've seen naked? It's crazy. Yes. And to someone
who you say is your partner is supposed to be? Right. Peep it.
Peep it. And this is why all this is happening.
When I saw this, I was really cuz it really made me look at her
differently. Okay? So, here's the Instagram and you can see these
posts for yourself. She got her into some tight dresses.
Bro, you are I I get I get exactly what God damn though. I mean
I guess well done Abba. I I I'll be real. Well done well done
Abba.
Well done, but also what are we doing here, bro? What are we
doing here? Like this is every single gym girl that's ever existed
post stuff just like this. You can't say that these are like
thirst traps and post because she's like a curvy woman. That's
crazy, dog. That's >> You know what I mean?
You know what I mean? She want to do a gym progress stuff. What
was crazy is that she was replying to every dude that I Okay?
>> You don't entertain what? Okay? Okay, I don't I don't
I don't I don't mind. She said these are not thirst traps, okay?
But mind you, there's just her of a her of a hot dress. >> Megyal
And she's replying to every dude on the planet. >> Megyal
You see it, right? I'm not tripping. You all see that? Megyal
Peep it. And she said to me this is when I found out I was like,
"Why did you lie to me the whole time?" Like that was really
off. And she denied it. She was losing her mind getting angry
at me. You want to know how fraudulent this broad is? I'll tell
you what she did. When I found out I texted her about it.
Not because I actually care about this kind of stuff. What that
hold on the comments? I I don't think the comments matter. I
I don't think they matter. I think they maybe So, that's where
the hypocrisy stuff could get annoying for
But I'm sorry. It's he's mad about the pictures. He's brought
up the comments second. There's a reason he brought up the comments
second and didn't go oh, there's nothing wrong with this and
that's why for me I was upset. Or sorry, there's nothing wrong
with the post, but I looked at comments and that's where there's
something wrong. He didn't present it like that. He pulled up
the
and then he goes, "Well, actually, look at this Look at this
Look at this posting these pictures." >> Then look, "You
see that she presented herself as something and she was doing
the opposite in hiding and pretended." So, when I texted her
about it, you know what I did before I texted her? I screen recorded
it, okay? When I told her about it and then she got on a call
later, you know what this girl did? She archived some of the
post. She archived it. Then when I questioned her about it, she
never answered. She would dodge the question. "You did this to
me. You did" And I'm like, "Why did you archive the post if you
felt like you did nothing shameful?" You'll see.
He got rid of it. She got rid of the whole account.
>> Okay. at the end of the day, I wish her the best of
luck. She can go do this with somebody else, whatever. She can
pretend she did nothing wrong cuz she always does that. But,
it is what it is. At the end of the day, it was a semi-messy
relationship, but it wasn't anything out of the ordinary. And
the fact that it's public, I would never want, but she chose
this life. >> it public. That's your fault. >> it
public. >> That is your fault. None of this None of this
could have went that way, but you went to Watts. You went to
this TV. You went to edit the fresh and fit. You went through
every to many more. And it's okay. It's okay. It's okay, my girl.
The whole problem with this [__] is not that you
got pregnant and you want it or not I you want it or not or want
it or not or want it or not to keep it. That's not the issue.
The issue is that you're a crazy [__] That's what
the problem is. I like just imagine how much of a loser you are
right now cuz you're over here posting all this [__]
online and like all the red pillers are going to look at you
like you're a Jezebel. And if that's what you want to do, then
go crazy, girl. You're giving fuel to all the >> I'm happy
You're giving >> and I not co-parenting, we not involved.
I got nothing to do with you. Your boy
You're giving fuel to all the people that think you are the norm,
my girl. By the end of the day, you really just it's just one
crazy out of many. But, you're you're you're just one crazy girl
out of many normal girls, right? It's you're The problem was
not the hormones.
Because the baby's not there no more, right? You still decide
to do this [__]
So, that's not I had nothing to do with the hormones. You crazy.
You go through You go through I I think the the relationship
ending badly, that that kind of seems like it would happen outside
the the hormones, but hey, whatever. Cuz y'all free. So y'all
can say whatever y'all want, but just think I might have been
tethered to that crazy for MY WHOLE LIFE.
NO. NO. OH, NO. OH, NO. Oh my god. Could you imagine? Could you
Oh my god, no.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
I'll go to my therapy. I'll do whatever I got to do, but your
boy happy. That's why I can show up to this life every day, cuz
just looking at her behavior right now, I texted her to this
thing today. I was like, "You doing this is making me so grateful
that we're here right now, cuz the opposite end is I might have
been with
I get to have a chance to be happy.
>> Well, she tried to pretend like she wasn't bothered.
She like, "All right, well, I'll do my other I'm like, "Do whatever
you got to do." Do your videos. You look stupid. >> I'm not
stressing. Genuinely. I got the recordings. I recorded it I As
soon as I realized this girl was recording, I was like, "Ooh."